[Musique]
patrick kanner le président du groupe
socialiste au sénat est l'invité
d'auditions publiques bonsoir soit un
pêcheur merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
notre invitation l'invitation des
chaînes parlementaires lcp assemblée
nationale public sénat de la fp du
figaro vous répondrez d'abord bien sûr
au premier ministre qui a donc restituer
ce matin le grand débat ce sera la
première partie avec stéphanie le rouge
et se fit d'avinel mesdames bon soir
dans ça ensuite monsieur canard est bien
avec brigitte boucher et au rayonnement
de chimie cette fois et bien vous alors
vous nous livrez avec franchise vos
états d'âme sur la liste de votre parti
aux européennes
et puis vous serez confrontés au cours
de cette émission à deux parlementaires
isabelle florennes député modem des
hauts-de-seine et jean-raymond hugonnet
que vous connaissez bien et les
sénateurs l'est républicain de l'essonne
le chat bien sûr comme chaque semaine
est ouvert pour les internautes du
figaro live dont j'attends bien sûr les
questions les réflexions des
commentaires première partie donc
d'auditions publiques c'est parti avec
vous monsieur kader la restitution donc
du grand débat par le premier ministre
ce matin vous l'avez suivi et puis on
est surtout maintenant dans la tente
évidemment des décisions du président de
la république mais est ce que vous
croyez à la capacité de l'exécutif de
répondre aux attentes des français
les français n'y croient pas
que les sondages de montres mais moi je
ne serai pas dans une démarche négative
je trouve que c'était osé de faire ce
pari du grand débat il est plutôt réussi
il est plutôt réussie disons le près de
deux millions de contributions un
million et demi de citoyens qui s'y sont
intéressés et qui ont même été actif
dans ce cadre là
maintenant la question c'est bien sûr
l'interprétation qui sera faite de ces
conclusions qui ont été présentés ce
matin par le premier ministre alors oui
c'est ça la question c'est plus les
aspirations fiscal oui mais avant même
cela est ce que les réponses étaient
prévues dans le bagage des ministres
avant même la conclusion c'est tout
ainsi activement la fait poser qu'on va
vous passez sur l'exaspération fiscale
est-ce que vous avez la même lecture que
le premier ministre sur cette question
est ce que vous voyez une exaspération
fiscale plutôt une demande de justice
fiscale et il est dans une démarche
idéologique le premier ministre moins
d'impôts moins d'impôts moins d'impôts
je suis un homme de gauche je crois à la
redistribution des richesses par l'impôt
si l'impôt est juste naturellement et
nous le verrons sûrement ensuite je
crois aussi maintenant de plus en plus à
la redistribution des pouvoirs entre les
français par rapport à leurs
représentants mais sur la partie fiscale
moins d'impôts c'est moins de services
publics c'est moins de services rendus à
ceux qui n'ont rien
public c'est le dernier bien qui
appartient à ceux qui n'ont rien et donc
moins d'impôts présenté comme un
principe je n'y contribuent absolument
pas je considère que il faut redéfinir
l'impôt le rendre acceptable et surtout
lui donner une mission qui est celle de
la répartition des richesses quand nous
proposons un isf versé pour permettre
que la transition écologique soit
notamment financé par ceux qui ont le
plus de moyens
voilà du sens politique à cette démarche
donc pas d'un pas de baisses d'impôts ok
je ne dis pas cela vous savez le
gouvernement auquel j'ai participé à
baisser les impôts à la fin du du
quinquennat certes on inventer des
impôts parce que vos débuts vous avez
vous même été rattrapé par la patrouille
merci monsieur moscovici différence
quand même c'est que nous avons trouvé
un pays qui était à 5 2% de déficit et
que nous l'avons ramené sur une tendance
à moins de 3%
lorsque nous avons laissé à l'actuel
gouvernement alors que c'est facile de
dire ce que vous dites alors vous dites
donc non aux baisses d'impôts
jeudi saint claud fiscalité une société
juste on ne peut pas en même temps ou
simultanément augmenter la csg des
retraités y compris les plus modestes
même si ça a bougé à la fin de l'année
2018 et permettre à 1 % des français de
récupérer 6 % de pouvoir d'achat en plus
parmi les plus fortunés de nos
concitoyens tant mieux pour eux mais
c'est tout à fait anormal et donc cette
exaspération
elle ne porte pas sur les impôts elle
porte sur l'injustice fiscale
en tout cas toucher à la tva parce que
justement une partie des demandes d'amis
qui ont été mises c'est de baisser cet
impôt notamment sur les produits de
première nécessité la tva c'est
noeux mémoire 50% des recettes de l'état
840 milliards d'euros on peut imaginer
qu'il y ait une belle sur une partie des
produits sur la restauration savait pas
donné grand chose avait pas de grand
chose devait se traduire rappelez-vous
par plus d'emplois ça n'a pas été du
tout le cas donc la tva est une recette
vraiment j'ai envie d'être est
importante pour payer les frais de
fonctionnement de l'état qui sont
finalement nos frais de fonctionnement à
nous salir nos services publics pourquoi
pas mais à condition encore une fois que
le fléchage soient claires enfin la
fraude fiscale jeu c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est assez important ça
revient beaucoup dans toutes les
campagnes escape a quelque chose à faire
est ce que chez les français il n'y a
pas cette revendication justement d'un
un travail qui soit faite sur la côte
fiscales qui ont été faits au dernier
quinquennat rappelez-vous toutes les
mesures qui avaient été prises par
christian équerre mon collègue en charge
du budget à l'époque une cellule avait
été imaginé d'ailleurs qui a disparu sa
ferme à part depuis un an des accords
ont été passés notamment avec louis
contre la suisse le luxembourg etc et et
d'autre part il reste à faire nous ont
été faites mais il ya encore 80
milliards d'euros qui s'échappait d'un
autre dans notre pays donc on a encore
beaucoup de travail
est ce que j'aime vraiment attendre la
part du premier ministre c'est pas des
prises de position à caractère
idéologique fermé mais en dix ans il y a
un problème de l'impôt dans notre pays
on met tout sur la table et on regarde
comment on peut la mission vous suis
quand même monsieur canard when it il
faut prendre plus aux riches hello les
1% les clients qui sont gagnants pour
pouvoir distribuer mais vous savez bien
que ça va marcher comme ça il faut bien
faire des économies est ce ça vous
accepté sur le principe de faire des
économies situeront sur ces tapis sont
riches c'est de remettre ce qui existait
précédemment et je commence le jour ce
revers ne suffira pas il faut bien faire
des économies parce que le premier 800
par l'otc monsieur rauscher
nous sommes arrivés à 3% enfin un peu
plus cette année avec notamment le
doublement du cic eux par la baisse des
cotisations sociales
donc on a dépassé les 3% du déficit de
maastricht très bien on va y revenir sur
moi l'année prochaine donc on est dans
les clous
on est dans les clous donc faut-il
encore baisser
la charge publique moi je ne participe
pas de cette petite musique qui consiste
à dire mais on dépense trop en france
pourquoi aujourd'hui ne pas considérer
notre modèle économique et social comme
un modèle protecteur pourquoi vouloir
toujours être pas au même niveau que les
autres
le déficit est bien mais nous sommes à
moins de 3% de la moindre bonne donc
tout va bien donc pourquoi faudrait-il
avoir moins de maternité en secteur
rural
pourquoi proposer avoir moins de tels
services publics dans le secteur des
politiques des gaines des quartiers de
politique de la ville
moi je n'accepte pas l'idée qu'on
dépense trop fonctions à dépenser mieux
peut-être mieux répartie vous défendez
l'idée que la france peut continuer à
vivre son déficit actuel je défends
cette idée et je défends l'idée du
modèle social de notre pays qui
peut-être est différent des autres mais
quand vous allez chez le médecin et
quand vous sortez non pas votre carte
bleue mais votre carte verte visa visa
pour le pour la bleue est vital pour
l'un vertes et bien vous n'êtes pas
mécontent du modèle social qui est le
nôtre
d'accord les familles vous parliez du
modèle social il ya une question qui est
sur la table en ce moment c'est celle de
la noue de l'âge de la de départ à la
retraite et de financement de la
dépendance
est ce que vous faites un lien entre ces
deux questions absolument pas j'ai
d'ailleurs plutôt aimé le propos de
monsieur de lauaki le haut commissaire
en charge de la réforme des retraites
qui a parlé de la polyphonie
gouvernemental où il est plutôt
charitable monsieur
delevoye on peut convenir a parlé de
cacophonie et pas n'importe laquelle
moi je me suis amusé en préparant notre
émission à regarder les déclarations des
uns des autres c'est quand même assez
extraordinaire entre monsieur griveaux
madame lizin qui s'est reconstruite au
moins trois ou quatre fois sur le sujet
devant les parlementaires en dehors des
parlementaires enfin on voit bien qu'il
est la tendance
la tendance est augmentée d'un an voire
de deux ans le bel âge de la retraite et
je pense que les propositions qui visent
à augmenter le financement pour la
dépendance par le biais d'une journée
complémentaires travailler c'est une
journée de pentecôte pour finalement
deux ans d'augmentation de du départ à
la retraite en termes d'années je n'y
crois pas tout d'abord parce que et je
reviendrai sur les dépendances
aujourd'hui de l'âge de départ vers tête
et 62 ans pour comme un trimestre je
ressors écouter ça fait 166 bravo merci
vous pourriez être à ma place et
trimestre ça signifie donc pour partir à
102 ans et vous avez fait le calcul il
faut avoir commencé à travailler à 21
ans et demi qui aujourd'hui travaillent
réellement à plein temps à 21 ans 8
peu de personnes avec les études qui
augmente c'est tant mieux donc 62 ans
c'est pas large de départ de la retraite
ce qui compte c'est le nombre de
trimestres cotisés qui vont augmenter
d'ailleurs dans les années à venir donc
on est là sur un totem qui est 62 ans il
faut le préserver surtout thème parce
que ça permet à quelqu'un de voir partir
même s'il a une décote mais pour avoir
une retraite à taux plein eh bien on
part à 63 4 ans déjà aujourd'hui donc
c'est un faux problème
et moi je me félicite que monsieur
delevoye reste sur son cap
la nuque raide en disant l'engagement du
prénom de république c'est 62 ans dans
le programme si ça je vous le dis très
simplement si cela devait être modifié
on créerait les conditions d'une d'un
nouveau problème anxiogène dans notre
pays qui aboutirait à de très très
grosses difficultés sur le plan social
donc ne si le gouvernement veut s'amuser
à cela ils prendraient de très très gros
risques après le grand débat et sur la
dépendance
ce sont deux problèmes différents
aujourd'hui il y à un million et demi de
français qui ont 85 ans
en 2030 2040 ils seront au moins 5
millions
donc il faut financer la dépendance et
moi y compris depuis très longtemps on
pouvait me reprendre sur mes propos
quand j'étais président de l'union
nationale des centres communaux d'action
sociale je lisais il faut créer un
cinquième risque
il faut encore isation des cotisations
en assurance obligatoire finances et
éventuellement par une redéfinition de
la femme crds qui va s'arrêter en 2024
donc là peut-être qu'on peut trouver
l'occasion mais je pense qu'on est
capable d'expliquer aux français que
cotiser par mois 5 ou 10 euros par
salariale complétée par une part
patronale de 5 ou 10 euros pour
permettre à chacun d'assumer la
dépendance de ses anciens haut
d'aujourd'hui
mais sa propre dépendance je pense que
les français sont capables pour ça que
le moins d'impôt n'a pas de sens qu'est
ce que nous c'est un donneur volontaire
jules vous allez trouver une adhésion il
faut trouver 10 milliards d'euros
on fait 3 milliards d'euros aujourd'hui
pour l'indépendance la journée de la
pentecôte ramène un milliard et demi on
sait bien que ce n'est pas suffisant
et moi je pense que notre pays
s'honorerait à prendre en charge ses
plus anciens dans l'oeuf qu'est ce que
vous pensez d'ailleurs petite musique
qui me fait penser à cela de certains de
nos voisins européens qui suggère que au
delà de 85 ans 90 ans mais plus de prise
en charge par exemple par l'état tu te
des soins 700 belges notamment en
belgique où 40 % des belges effectuent
ces risques il faut arrêter pour
financer la sécu on arrête de souiller
les personnes ça me rappelle le film sur
l' hiver samedi quelque chose on
considérait qu'à 60 ans à l'époque et
bien il fallait l'euthanasier les
personnes cgt absolue est donc ce qui
peut imaginer cela
me font penser à des réflexes politiques
et idéologiques des années 40 socialiste
notamment du nord monsieur là on parle
et j'ai une vision utilitariste de la
société une question anglo saxon la
belgique
la question se pose en bretagne est
également aux pays bas où on finance
plus par exemple mais pacemaker j'ai les
personnes de plus de soixante dix ans ce
n'est pas mon modèle social on n'y aura
ni morale surtout pour revenir sur ce
qui est ressorti du grand débat national
sur le plan institutionnel il ya une
forte appétence pour la reconnaissance
du vote blanc est pour l'extension du
référendum d'initiative partagée quelle
position vous avez sur sur ces sujets
qui nécessiterait une réforme
constitutionnelle alors le vote blanc je
suis plutôt favorable sous réserve que
on est à côté le vote obligatoire
voilà c'est l'un et l'autre vont de pair
ils sont indissociables en tout cas dans
la conception qui alors le vote est
obligatoire
le problème c'est que il n'est
obligatoire que le nom et que quand je
vois mes amis belges ont parlé de la
belgique
il ne fonctionne pas ça fonctionne pas
et ça ne faut que je m'aime pas pour le
seul vote obligatoire qui existent en
france pour le sénateur dire j'ai
interrogé le préfet du nord au moment
des élections sénatoriales de 2017 je
lui disais mais je préfère est ce que
vous allez sanctionner les grands
électeurs qui n'ont pas voté
j'ai pas les moyens et ça coûterait plus
cher d'aller les sanctionner bon donc
très réservé un vote obligatoire sans
sanctions applicables
il a peu de chances d'être vraiment
différent dames viennent essayer alors
sur le rip le référendum steve partager
créé par nicolas sarkozy en 2008 mais
dont une réforme n'a jamais été mis en
oeuvre
sachant que l' ordonnance d'application
été prise par le gouvernement de
françois hollande sous l'autorité de
françois hollande applicable à partir
donc de 2015 il faut 20 % de
parlementaires qui signent donc ça veut
dire 185 parlementaire c'est trop il
faut en aval du conseil constitutionnel
est ensuite 10 % du corps électoral
j'assiste aux réunions de travail de
gérard larcher sur cette question et la
proposition qui est celle de gérard
larcher et donc du sénat c'est simple
c'est non pas 20 % des parlementaires
mais 10% donc passer à la moitié de ce
que prévu aujourd'hui et même chose pour
les électeurs c'est à dire qu on
ramènerait non pas 4 millions 700 mille
signatures
mais à deux millions deux cent deux sans
trois donc ça ça me paraît beaucoup plus
raisonnable et je pense que le rip n'est
pas la réponse aux fameux bric
on a fait un homme digne et citoyenne
mais c'est un outil que nous avons
aujourd'hui en mains qu'il faut savoir
expérimenté puisqu'il faut un référendum
cette fois pour sortir de cette période
de grands débats selon vos pour
peut-être entrer dans la deuxième phase
du quinquennat
je ne sais pas si le président a ça en
tête on parle même de référendum à
questions multiples par exemple votre
suggestion si vous en avez vu surtout
souhaité que j'essaie je ne suis pas pro
référendum par principe parce que
souvent les questions qui sont posées
font l'objet de réponses qui n'ont rien
à voir avec la question même mais ouais
vous inciter à être favorable mais il
radote commandité par le chef de l'état
mais je suis je vous dis je pense que
aujourd'hui le chef de l'état a besoin
de se sortir d'un guêpier
mais il a eu besoin de sortir par le
haut du grand débat le grand débat a
suscité une très grande attente
s'il aboutit à une très grande
dispersion une très grande frustration
je ne sais pas ce que deviendra notre
notre pays finalement emmanuel macron à
gagner du temps oui mais ce que la
question c'est en gagnant du temps et je
reprends une expression que j'ai ma plus
de d'hervé gattegno votre collègue du
jdd il ya dix mais il a gagné du temps
est ce qu'il a fait perdre notre temps
suivante parce que regarder pour les
mesures qui sont annoncées de
restitution de ce grand débat on va au
delà des européennes on arrive juste
qu'avant l'été
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment là
qu'il était entré un peu de manipuler le
calendrier politique pour passer les
européennes sous silence et ne pas en
faire justement un référendum je fais
confiance à paroles du président il a
dit qu'il ferait ses premières annonces
dès la semaine prochaine dès la semaine
prochaine on sera attendu jusqu alors si
je ne voudrais pas c'est qu'on me dise
qu'on nous dise qu'on dise aux français
c'est tellement riche le grand débat
qu'il faudra prendre du temps et comme
par hasard le temps ce serait après donc
la procrastination c'est à dire le
report de la décision
utile je pense ne trompera personne en
la matière donc le président a pris un
risque avec ce grand débat il a été
réussi ce risque
ce pari au niveau de la forme maintenant
on l'attend sur le fond bon vous lui
souhaiter de réussir quand même dans le
sang je jure le pays
je souhaite surtout que la déception des
français ne soient pas à la hauteur de
leurs aspirations
d'accord dernière question pour cette
partie stéphanie oui le gouvernement a
l'air prêt à renoncer à une mesure
emblématique celle sur les 80 kilomètres
heure qui avait partiellement déclenché
la colère déjà des automobilistes qu'est
ce que vous pensez de ça c'était la
seule mesure d'edouard philippe un petit
peu qu'il portait lui
oui sur lequel il s'est engagé la rapée
ce matin 10 ans et moi moi seule
préoccupation c'était moi sont morts sur
les routes
on a cru que j'ai déjà décidé ça pour
remplir les caisses
je n'ai pas moi je ne sens pas les reins
et les coeurs
le coeur de ce que je sais c'est que
dans la verticalité du pouvoir qui a été
celle de des 18 premiers mois du
quinquennat décidé sa seule avec ses
collaborateurs de matignon sans passer
par
en fait ceux qui savent et ceux qui
savent en l'occurrence des collectivités
locales c'est le collectif et en
particulier les présidents de conseils
départementaux j'ai été président du
conseil général du nord avec messi milo
km 6000 km2 c'est ce que parmi les
membres s'étaient délégué la sueur mais
donc ce que j'ai envie de dire entre un
ministre mais sachez écouter et si vous
écoutez bien vous serez entendre ce
qu'ils aient la sagesse et l'utilité
pour notre pays donc les et le grand
débat permet de sortir de ce bunker de
certitudes qui a été la marque de
fabrique de la première partie du
quinquennat temps mais pour le pays mais
je n'en suis pas certain merci mesdames
c'est la fin de la première partie
d'émission public te souhaiter deux
parlementaires vont faire leur rentrée
donc je vous l'annonçais isabelle
florennes et jean-raymond hugonnet
bonsoir bonsoir à tous les deux je vous
en prie prenaient place autour de cette
table face à monsieur tonnerre qui va
vous répondre dans un instant la
question d'un internaute du figaro qui
souhaite que le salaire des sénateurs
soit divisée par deux on n'a pas parlé
du nombre de parlementaires mais on l'a
on parle du salaire et l'internaute
demande est ce que vous y être
favorables non non non parce que je ne
participe pas du tout à cette démagogie
qui consisterait à penser que les élus
sont trop payés parce que finalement
c'est quoi l'indemnité des sénateurs
d'un maire d'un président de conseil
général départemental ou régional
c'est le moyen pour la démocratie
d'avoir des représentants qui ne soit
pas où issu de la plutocratie ou de la
gérontocratie voilà et donc si on veut
des personnes qui consacrent leur temps
à la vie publique
il faut qu'ils puissent être
correctement indemnisée pour éviter
toute forme de pression donc vraiment
pour moi c'est de c'est de la démagogie
et d'ailleurs je suis cet internaute se
voyait dire eh bien moi je dis me par
deux passants qui seraient contents et
sur la baisse du nombre de
parlementaires je suis opposé à
également et bien sûr j'y suis opposée
parce que personne n'a encore démontré
en quoi la baisse du nombre de
parlementaires améliorerait la vie
démocratique de notre pays
le seul qui a réussi à baisser le
parlementaire dans notre pays 2 ça
remonte à quelques temps c'est napoléon
iii j'ai passé prendra public a envie
d'être le dindon 3 du 21e siècle mais
baissé de parlementaires baisser le
nombre d'élus ça n'améliore pas pour moi
la démocratie et nous sommes aujourd'hui
un nombre de parlementaires qui n'a pas
bougé depuis 1984 et depuis 1984
nous avons pris près de 12 millions
d'habitants en plus dans notre pays donc
contact très bien alors donc nos deux
parlementaires je voulais présente à
nouveau joyeusement hugonnet bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes collègues de notre
invité
sénateur l'est républicain de l'essonne
et madame florennes vous êtes donc
député modem des hauts-de-seine alors
qu'ils commencent madame florennes
peut-être vous avez entendu le président
du patron des sénateurs socialistes
réagir aux grands débats et aux mesures
attendues une interpellation
oui moi je suis plutôt sensible à ce que
disait monsieur président et monsieur k
nerfs sur l'interprétation en tout cas
ce que vous avez entendu du premier
ministre et sur la question de la
justice fiscale plutôt que de la
question uniquement de la baisse des
impôts mais par rapport à sa gêne pas
c'est juste une interpellation j'ai posé
une question pour ça et alors je veux je
suis plutôt sensible à cette lecture
puisque au modem nous faisons aussi avec
françois bayrou une lecture plus proche
de celle de la justice que de celle
d'avoir entendu que de la queue de la
volonté de presse flores vous êtes en
tête de nous dire que la sur la question
grillé c'est par exemple vous vous êtes
plus proche parti socialiste
démissionnaire que de vos partenaires de
la république en large et bien compris
alors nous avions une proposition de la
part ferme et là je réponds je ne sais
pas exactement quelle est la proposition
de monsieur k nerfs sur l' isf c'est
simple c'est le rétablissement de lier
ces fous de l'équivalent mais fléchit
totalement vers la transition écologique
alors c'est pas assez pas là nous c'est
sur l'investissement productif sur
l'emploi ça peut se rejoindre sur la
position est correctement et que tu
appuies sur l'emploi monsieur venait
alors ma première interpellation s'était
pas celle que j'avais prévu en préférant
cette émission mais en écoutant mon cher
collègue patrick kanner tout à l'heure
sur la situation financière du pays nous
dire que tout va bien j'ai eu
l'impression d'avoir des bourdonnements
parce que avec 100 milliards de déficit
annuel 2300 milliards de dettes visible
c'est le stock visible il ya 4500
milliards de dette qui passe d'ailleurs
sous le contrôle du parlement ce sont
les engagements hors bilan de l'état ça
a été critiquée par la cour des comptes
nous dire que tout va bien
chers collègues ça je ne peux pas
l'entendre mais je
je n'ai pas dit que tout allait bien la
situation récupérer en 2017 par monsieur
mac ont été bien meilleures que celles
récupérées par françois hollande avec vu
tout à l'heure le déficit c'est le prix
de notre modèle il faut le préserver
mais mais mais là on est en désaccord
avec monsieur ghosn m
oui normal jiri les je suis de gauche à
droite et nous croyons l'un et l'autre
d'ailleurs l'alternance
donc c'est tout tout tout va bien dans
le meilleur des mondes ce que je crois
moi c'est que baisser la dépense
publique est comme un principe ne
correspond pas à la demande des français
d'ailleurs ils l'ont exprimé depuis
notamment le grand débat que la dépense
publique soit mieux orienter plus fléchi
et permettre au territoire de ne pas se
sentir en relégation en déclassement
bien sûr je pense que là nous serons
d'accord en tant que sénateur nous
savons ce que veut dire le mot
territoire rural dans notre dans notre
pays mais on ne veut pas on ne peut pas
baisser entre la dépense publique sans
toucher au nombre de fonctionnaires
je suis hugonnet a soutenu un candidat
qui avait prévu la baisse de cinq cents
mille postes de fonctionnaires et donc
ça son poste par rapport aux 120 mille
postes prévues par monsieur macro on
était quatre fois plus donc on n'est pas
sur les mêmes données
moi je respecte la position de la droite
elle est constante
je pense que le respect est partagée sur
la position qui est la nôtre mais les
français aujourd'hui ne demande pas
moins de services publics il faut leur
parler aussi aux français il faut leur
dire la vérité ou leur ment depuis 40
ans sur la situation réelle financière
de nos paies de notre pays qui est en
jeu leur dis en faillite
qu'il faille bien entendu défendre notre
modèle c'est là où je vous rejoins ce
modèle qui est le meilleur du monde
qu'il faille le défendre oui mais il a
un coût et il a une responsabilité et on
ment aux français au quotidien sur
l'état de notre pays car d'avoir vous le
faites ce reproche à monsieur canard ils
morts en dix ans
contre ils nous servent dans un débat
apaisé des cantons bien que tout va bien
c'est une honte on comprend ce que je
dis c'est que longuement aux français
depuis 40 ans sur l'état de notre pays
et que on est en train de mettre en pays
en péril par dont un système qui est le
meilleur du monde parce que nous sommes
inconscient là dessus moi je suis senti
beaucoup donné sur le fait que notre
dette cumulée représente l'équivalent de
notre produit intérieur brut
vous avez appartenir à un gouvernement
que quand même essayer de faire des
économies oui via les très grands noms
mais quand même et le conduit encore une
fois qui a ramené déficit de 5 2 % à 3 %
donc nous avons fait des efforts que
nous en fait d'ailleurs partagé aussi
avec les collectivités territoriales et
donc il y à un équilibre à trouver entre
la dette publique cumulée
dont acte et le modèle social et c'est
ça c'est de la porte étroite vous avez
il doit résorber le scoring vous vouliez
intervenir sur ce sujet clé tout à fait
la question de la décentralisation moi
j'ai un regard un peu critique quand
même sur le mandat de françois et
l'homme sur cette question est
d'ailleurs à l'issue du grand débat un
certain nombre de français qui sont
venus débattre nous font part de leur
désarroi notamment sur la loi de
métropolisation la loi notre qui a
notamment regroupé contraint et forcé un
certain nombre de deux communes en
intercommunalités et les ministres et le
président de la république semble
vouloir revenir sur cette loi et nous
pensons de notre côté que au contraire
il faut plus de décentralisation est
notamment allé vers aussi des démarches
de différenciation sur certains
territoires je voulais avoir connaître
votre opinion sur le sujet et notamment
sur la question aussi du conseiller
territorial qui avait été supprimée par
par le gouvernement sous françois
hollande et qui avait été introduit par
nicolas sarkozy et qui pouvait
constituer éventuellement une solution
alors alors prenons la dernière sur le
conseiller territorial sens
j'en veux dire embêter les
téléspectateurs sur un sujet qui peut
permettre technique mais qui finalement
est très politique faut-il que un même
élu soit en charge des compétences de la
région et du département je ne le crois
toujours pas d'accord encore une fois
j'étais président du département et le
travail qui était celui de françois
hollande et de ses différents ministres
en charge c'était de mieux répartir les
compétences entre la région et le
département aujourd'hui les régions par
exemple sont totalement compétente sur
les questions et économique
les départements sur les questions de
solidarité entre les personnes et entre
le territoire et donc je pense qu'il
faut deux types d'élus différents un élu
élu sur un territoire
le conseiller départemental même
aujourd'hui en binôme permettant ainsi
la parité est un élu élu sur un projet
politique sur la base de la
proportionnelle c'est le conseiller
régional donc relier les deux je ne sais
pas comment on fait c'est le mariage
pour moi que de la carpe et du lapin
d'une nouvelle étape de la
décentralisation indispensable
indispensable moi je ne regrette pas la
fusion des régions je sais que c'est
très compliqué tiens savez nous on a
dans ma région des hauts de france le
nord pas de calais qui a été fusionné
avec la picardie c'est compliqué il
faudra du temps il faut laisser du temps
au temps comme diraient certains
mais nous avons maintenant treize
régions hexagonales qui sont à la taille
des régions du reste de l'europe pour ça
d'ailleurs que je suis aussi
départementaliste je crois qu'il faut un
échelon intermédiaire entre le niveau
communal et niveau régional par contre
et là où je vous rejoins plutôt madame
c'est qu'il faut que la commune s'y
retrouve
il faut que l'élu de proximité et ça a
été très bien vu dans le grand débat s'y
retrouve
est-ce que l'intercommunalité est un
risque pour les élus communaux je ne
crois pas parce que face aux métropoles
et on ne pourra pas empêcher le
phénomène de métropolisation qui
s'impose à nous à nous comme ailleurs
dans le monde
eh bien il faut qu'il y ait des
intercommunalités à caractère rural qui
permettent de enfin j'ai envie d'être de
créer un équilibre sur le sur les
territoires il est trop tôt pour jean
veut dire juge
la loi de l'autre elle n'a que 3 ans ou
quatre ans donc laissons-le a impacté
les territoires au meilleur sens du
terme
très bien alors ce fossé en tous les cas
entre les métropoles le reste du
territoire a été évoqué par le premier
ministre aujourd'hui jean raymond
hugonnet vous vouliez aborder un autre
sujet mais oui un peu d'éclectisme
l'année chez honda on va pas refaire adp
je voulais je voulais parler d'eux
mais si vous voulez on parle adp d'abord
si j'ai le temps pour lui de poser une
autre question à les y voilà
alors l'autre question c'est puisque on
a fait un ancien ministre des sports que
pense-t-il l'ancien ministre des sports
de la façon dont madame maracineanu
ministre des sports actuelle a
stigmatisé le monde de football
s'agissant de l'homophobie
alors il y a cet épisode
moi vous savez je fais partie d'un
gouvernement qui a tout fait pour
empêcher le hooliganisme avec mon
collègue thierry braillard que je tiens
à saluer quitter ce que dans l'état nous
avons eu à gérer les fameuses attaques
et insultes racistes dans certains
matches que je n'évoquerai pas et en
tout cas je suis pour la tolérance zéro
les champs où ils sont donc toujours la
riche amant comme le pg faire le grenier
de la part de l' arbitre d'une cessation
bien sûr ce navire et qu' arrêter un
match en demandant effectivement à ce
que les choses se régularise sachant que
de plus en plus nous avons des
vidéosurveillances et heureusement dans
les stades qui permet de repérer ce qui
est un délit il faut lui dire si vous
êtes quand même du côté de l'actuel
ministre jugeant que pour les autorités
du foot voilà le président de la
fédération ou la président de la ligue
nationale de football a évoqué la notion
de folklore et le folklore il faut pas
sortir les mots du contexte je pense que
noël le graet a fait la parfaite réponse
en disant qu'il n'avait pas de leçon à
recevoir de quiconque sur ce thème
puisque le football est le seul sport ou
en tout cas un des seuls sports qui déjà
au niveau des ligues des districts à une
action éducative
voilà et réduire les supporters du
football à des décérébrés qui viennent
dans un stade que ça soit à lille à nice
ou ailleurs c'est absolument intolérable
parce que là encore la ministre il en a
pas je vois comment non mais on sait
qu'il y avait eu des problèmes
voilà peu importe mais en tout cas il
n'y a pas de distinction à faire tout le
monde condamne le mot phobie très
clairement mais c'est net partout noël
le graet le premier en revanche
stigmatisé comme on l'a fait ou nous
faire croire qu'une interdiction ou
pourquoi pas des taxes non plus pendant
qu'on y est suffirait à éradiquer ce
fléau
c est extensible et je ne vous cache pas
que puisque le match avait lieu dans
chez moi où tu as deux cas me roy
guingamp strasbourg finale la coupe de
la ligue et j'ai été un peu étonné de ne
pas voir la ministre
dans merci chers collègues dans le salon
des autorités par excusez moi je n'ai
loupé aucun aucune aborder la fonction
aujourd'hui du jugement si vous posez
pas de questions sur le rôle et
l'utilité du ministère des sports
ah merci vous lisez vous lisez dans mes
pensées alors oui je sais pourquoi parce
que quand même ce ministère et le
ministère qui est le plus mal traités
je suis d'accord alors qu'aujourd'hui
c'est les fonds diminue les dotations
diminue on essaie de nous faire croire
qu'ils augmentent mais quand vous savez
qu'on prépare les jeux olympiques en
fait ils diminuent on déshabille paul
pour habiller jacques
alors que le sport est le vecteur
principal du collectif de l'intégration
et de ce qu'on peut faire avec le sport
de ce que l'on peut montrer à la société
avec le sport dieu sait si notre pays en
a besoin
je suis moi extrêmement choqué de la
manière dont d'abord le ministère de
laura flessel et maintenant celui de
roxana maracineanu fonctionne j'ai porté
notamment la candidature des géo pour
paris 2024 deux ans de travail avec le
succès positif qu'une que nous
connaissons je suis totalement effaré de
voir que l'un des rares budgets qui a
diminué c'est celui du sport on vient
d'avoir les géo et on diminue pour la
deuxième fois consécutive
objet du sport la ministre est en train
de négocier avec les fédérations
sportives le transfert de 1600 postes de
conseiller technique et sportif c'est à
dire ceux qui finalement repère les
futurs champions ce qui viennent
encadrer les clubs lenteur le ministère
pendant pour moi c'est un ministre
fossoyeur un ministre fossoyeurs qui va
transformer progressivement elle et ses
successeurs
ce ministère qui a été créé dans sa
configuration ministère des sports et
jeunesse par herzog
c'est une histoire c'est pas mon
histoire politique d'une histoire dans
le symbolisme et qui considère le sport
comme étant un vecteur d'épanouissement
de liberté de lien social
c'est un message le sport c'est 34
millions de pratiquants dans le pays 17
millions de licenciés 17 millions
pratiquants elles ne sont pas essentiels
ils sont toujours bien sûr qu'ils vont
rester mais avec quels moyens moi je
revendique une compétence régalienne
pour le sport dans notre pays et je
considère que affaiblir le sport c'est
un c'est une manière finalement de
considérer cette activité humaine comme
étant résiduelles fossoyeur le mot est
fort pour nous à un moment où on parle
du sport santé bon je pense qu'il faut
remonter au moment où on va accueillir
la coupe du monde féminine de football
en 2010 neuf où on est donc ce qui
allons organiser les jo en 2024 la coupe
du monde de rugby en 2023
j'ai participé à tous ces choix tous ces
dossiers et je considère que les fameux
petits 500 millions d'euros du sport en
france
on aurait dû avoir un plan de
financement du sport jusqu'en 2024 a
mené un doublé du sport de l'écologie
alors je les entends et j'ai entendu des
critiques sur les présidents et des
postes techniques qui avaient été soit
disant supprimer j'ai cru comprendre que
la ministre était revenu après
discussion il ya quelques mois sur
justement la suppression la non
suppression de ces postes on s'écoute
devos et les fédéraux oui eh bah écoutez
moi j'ai pas j'ai pas eu la même la même
lecture je suis pas jour après jour les
décisions et les lignes budgétaires
concernant le ministère tout ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que notamment avec
mon groupe nous sommes très attachés
notamment à maintenir une trésorerie
pour les associations et à maintenir des
associations notamment sportives et à
faire un effort et apporter à chaque
fois qu'on le pouvait dans l'hémicycle
sur nos niches parlementaires c'est à
dire nos espaces de groupes
parlementaires
ddd justement propositions qui vont dans
le sens d'améliorer le financement des
associations j'ai bien conscience que
sur ce domaine
le gouvernement a eu des mauvaises
directions à une mauvaise direction au
départ en supprimant notamment la
question des contrats aidés et donc on
le sait très bien qu'il faut revenir
alors par d'autres mesures sur cette
question notamment vous parliez du sport
loisirs du sport pour tous et des
emplois moi j'en parle dans les
quartiers que vous connaissez bien et
quartiers politique de
il s'est pas sont essentiels payet des
quartiers précaires de la ville des
clubs sportifs sont touchés par les
phénomènes de radicalisation c'est si
vous leur enlevez les contrats aidés etc
eh bien vous laisse ou mettez un risque
potentiel de prédateur sur ces clubs
notamment dans ces quartiers le sport au
féminin dans ces quartiers est majeur en
termes de d'image mais aussi en termes
de d'épanouissement pour les femmes et
de liberté pour les femmes
si vous supprimez les contres année
c'est la même chose donc les contrées
néanmoins la baisse des crédits au
niveau ministériel
la suppression des comptes des
conseillers techniques et sportifs ça
fait beaucoup quand même pour un seul
ministre alors il reste quelques minutes
pour aborder bon j'ai cité adp tout à
l'heure mais je le connais oui c'est
cela c'est un sujet qui vous préoccupe
tous les toits sur la privatisation d'un
épais là encore c'est un vrai sport et
la privatisation dans notre pays c'est
un vrai sport les mêmes qui à l'époque
ont été les fossoyeurs
j'en reviens aux fossoyeurs je vais pas
faire de publicité mais on se croirait
chez borloo ceux qui ont bradé les
autoroutes
aujourd'hui brad adp bruno le maire
était directeur de cabinet de monsieur
de villepin quand les autoroutes ont été
bradées donc nous avons dit j'ai fait
partie les politiques eux mêmes avec
cardon vos amis politiques à l'époque
mais attendez pas de problème elle n'y a
pas de souci avec ça soyons tous égaler
les dons qu'ils tombent et reconnaissons
les erreurs anglais le tout chaud et je
crois que là-dessus les français ont
compris que sur tous les bons voilà
personne
c'est terrible là on est tout à fait
d'accord avec nous et on a fait partie
chacun donnant sur nos vies respectives
de ce dossier n'a poussé au sénat bien
entendu mais la sagesse vient du sénat
vous ça alors question alors la question
à l'audience et le féliciter pour ce
combat commun ah ben on a eu l'occasion
de le faire en revanche le référendum
d'initiative partagée
là je n'y crois pas de seconde c'est la
raison pour laquelle je n'ai pas signé
l'engagement que nous proposait patrick
kanner parce que là encore c'est la
représentation populaire on essaie de
nous faire croire que les députés des
sénateurs quel qu'il soit serait des
gens hors sol qui ne représenterait pas
la population dans notre pays la
cinquième la vème république et sa
constitution font des représentants et
du parlement les représentants du peuple
et des territoires
les choses sont très claires nous avons
à prendre des positions et nous nous
sommes d'avis de dire nous avons exprimé
tous les griefs que nous avions contre
la privatisation de la dp maintenant il
faut que le gouvernement assume et porte
devant notre pays qui aujourd'hui est un
pays clairement en difficulté avec des
gens dans la rue qu'il porte que l'on
brade les bijoux de famille quelques
secondes pour conclure sa gpu affaires
économiques politiques financières
environnementales
cette privatisation est un non sens que
nous allons continuer à combattre avec
le différentes méthodes et je rejoins me
suis donné c'est un très mauvais choix
et c'est un choix très court terme de la
part du gouvernement
il faudra que les français soient juges
et fasse l'inventaire de ce choix merci
merci à tous les deux fière d'avoir
participé à cette édition d'auditions
publiques je vous libère
vous allez laisser votre place
maintenant à brigitte boucher et à
oriane mancini qui font leur entrée sur
ce plateau pour la dernière partie
bonsoir mesdames si d'être là fidèle au
rendez-vous patrick kanner une question
d'un internaute du figaro il s'appelle
hervé vous êtes sensible aux totems de
la gauche
chou est ce que vous êtes toujours
attachés aux 35 heures selon cet
internaute
les 35 heures ont paupérisé les bas
salaires il parle notamment des ouvriers
et des jeunes pour satisfaire dit-il le
confort
si je fais le lien que le grand débat
qui a demandé dans le grand débat la
suppression des 35 heures personne
donc c'est un totem utile pour notre
pays organiserait félix man de ses
premiers pas il a participé à son
premier débat avec les autres têtes de
liste jeudi soir premier meeting de
campagne samedi à toulouse
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ses
premiers pas ils sont pas simples pour
lui l'a reconnu d'ailleurs
voilà je l'aï même pas un professionnel
de la politique voilà il a deux mois
pour convaincre et on va tous le faire
on va tous l'aider pour qu'il puisse
convaincre un maximum de deux français
ont lancé l'opération survie déjà non
écoutés aujourd'hui les sondages sont ce
qu'ils sont 5
je regardais les différents rowling là
qui sortent tous les jours on est à 5 5
et demi six parfois donc si ça c'est pas
extraordinaire
écoutez moi je me suis exprimé moment
venu mais les militants socialistes je
suis militant socialiste ont tranché et
moi je serai derrière raphaël glucksmann
dans cette campagne si bien sûr on fait
appel à moi et je n'en doute pas nous
recevons demain au groupe socialiste
olivier faure et ma première question à
olivier faure sera olivier qu'est ce que
tu as besoin de nous pour que cette
campagne prennent et puisse marquer des
points dans l'esprit des français
c'est vrai que la gauche dont confettis
aujourd'hui malheureusement et qu' il
peut y avoir des votes utiles en disant
mais si on veut contrer
le ratio national est ce qu'il faut pas
voter pour emmanuel macron alors qu'on
est social démocrate
j'entends ou lis ps est-ce que c'est pas
l'expression du ps derrière moi j'étais
favorable à une tête de liste ps et en
particulier d'olivier fort la choix
stratégique a été fait autrement
conforter confirmé par le vote des
militants donc moi vous savez je suis
très clair dans ma tête c'était pas mon
choix un choix autre a été affichée
annoncée et confirmée par les militants
je serai derrière je choix maintenant à
chacun de retrait pour la tête de pages
accuse bien sûr après la question qui
est posée aujourd'hui c'est de l'aider à
prendre tout son espace
le fait de dire que je ne suis pas un
pro chaine la politique ce n'est pas
suffisant mais c'est en fait socialisme
couramment est-ce qu'ils parlent aux
socialistes
oui mais le à prendre leur la sincérité
le nouveau style pourquoi pas il faut
que ça se traduit également pourquoi
paru dans l'est dans les urnes on parce
qu'à un moment donné
l'inventaire issa pardon est-ce que vous
pensez que s'il peut vous coûter cher
dans les urnes escale force d'apparaître
décalé ne va pas paraître comme amateur
c'est à lui j'ai envie dire de de s'auto
regarder il a un style
il a un style c'est pas le mien c'est le
bon allez je doute je vais tout vous
dire j'ai dû avait tranché je pense je
pense que la politique c'est pas un
métier mais qu'il est à savoir faire et
qu'en l'occurrence dire je ne suis pas
un politique professionnelle faut pas
que ce soit une injure pour tous ceux
qui ont consacré et qui consacrent leur
vie à l'intérêt général ce que je fais
et moi je ne veux pas être entre
guillemets minorés donc il a a progressé
et je suis prêt à prendre ma part dans
cette progression pour que le 26 mai on
ne soit pas à 5% mais a bien plus
combien c'est un travail et combien
l'objectif pour ça mais il faut être
raisonnable
pour faire
si certains disent un score à deux
chiffres
bon si on était à 8 ou 9 ce serait une
formidable je me dirais étape pour
demain notre parti politique parce que
en dessous
olivier faur devra tirer les
conséquences alors vous écouter on n'est
pas là pour tirer les inventaires avant
même que le score soit affichée le 26
mai au soir
donc moi je prendrai ma part encore une
fois les sénateurs socialistes prendront
leur part malgré les réserves des uns et
des autres sur la stratégie qui a été
adopté mais elle a été adoptée le parti
en randonnée on ne fait pas de politique
uniquement en gardant son rétroviseur
il faut faire il faut avancer et c'est
notre tête de liste ce que je lui
demande simplement c'est des preuves
d'amour l'épreuve l'épreuve par exemple
il nous a confirmé qu'il allait adhérer
au groupe s'il était élu bien évidemment
et je l'espère au groupe et samedi donc
le groupe socialiste et démocrate au
sein du parlement européen
mais il a 10 mai
adhérer au pse s'est pas encore ma tasse
de thé
grosso modo et on va essayer de faire
bouger les choses
je lui demande un peu d'humilité ce
n'est pas avec quelques députés
européens issus de cette liste qu'on
fera bouger un groupe qui fait plus de
cent personnes donc attention
en tout cas j'ai une demande de
considérer que s'il est élu ce sera
avant tout grâce aux forces du parti
vous avez parlé de valeurs qu'elle
assiégeait chez les verts donc ça veut
dire que d'ores et déjà à l'arrivée il y
aura un groupe qui va une liste qui va
s'éclater dans différents groupes
je pense que le propos dehors là lui
était sûrement sincère transparent mais
quand on fait de la politique et à ce
niveau là il faut savoir tourner sa
langue sept fois dans sa bouche
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure vous avez
des mots forts pour la ministre des
sports vous avez parlé vous avez parlé
du fossoyeur
mais il ya aussi des fossoyeurs au parti
socialiste des lions bah je vais vous
poser la question vous c'est l'histoire
de toute votre vie patrick ewing c'est
ma vie ces images c'est ma famille
schéma c'est ma seconde famille hélas
parfois même la première votre parti
vous le voyez en train de mourir à je ne
vois pas en bonne santé oui
malheureusement et c'est une
meurtrissure pour moi je le dis avec
beaucoup d'émotions vous avez donc ils
ont cédé 3 la vie politique et que donc
je ne me résigne pas je ne me résous pas
considérer que la social-démocratie de
gouvernement cette gauche gouvernement
soit morte elle est mal en point
aujourd'hui chaque étape doit être
considérée comme étant une épreuve de
vérité et et moi je continuerai à me
battre jusqu'au bout
je compte il faut pour que votre
quartier il faut sûrement qu' ils soient
fiers de lui de ses racines du
quinquennat françois hollande voulait
dire
mais bien sûr enfin moi je n'y a pas eu
des erreurs comme indécent le répondre
s'il vous plaît mais doit être fier du
quinquennat ce n'est pas de dire pour
autant qu'on est béat à 100 % ce qui
s'est passé le seul le premier qui
d'ailleurs qu'il a écrit c'est françois
hollande lui même quand vous lisez sont
son livre là il est tout à fait
transparent par rapport à soi par
rapport à la déchéance par rapport au
vote des étrangers par rapport à la
fiscalité qu'il est trop lourde au début
du quinquennat mais dans les conditions
qu'on ait évoqué l eur de déficit donc
il y a eu ou des erreurs ou des
malentendus des controverses mais il ya
eu tellement de choses positives dans ce
quinquennat qui n'ont pas pu être
défendu pendant la campagne
présidentielle et moi ce que je souhaite
aujourd'hui c'est que si on veut
reconquérir et je reprends l'expression
la métaphore le coeur et les reins des
français et bien il faut que on leur
parle de lutte contre les inégalités
qu'on leur parle de développement
durable et d'écologie mais qui va bien
plus loin que l'environnement qu'on leur
parle de nouvelles libertés la
décentralisation mais aussi de grandes
réformes qui touchent à la vie alain
team je pense notamment à la fin de vie
qui aujourd'hui au milieu du guizhou
permettez l'expression en termes de
réponse législative
moi je veux que cette gauche
apparaissent comme étant une alternative
potentielle à ce ni droite ni gauche
emmanuel macron qui pour l'instant est
plutôt nigauds nigauds chacun voudra
bien que mon accord mais alors on
parlait de françois hollande
il pronostique l'arrivée de l'extrême
droite dans notre pays
peut-être pas la prochaine
présidentielle la fois d'avant il dit
les français diront on a tout essayé
mais ce qu'il ne s'exonère pas un peu
légèrement de sa propre responsabilité
il fait appel au contraire un autre
responsabilité sur le thème que tout est
possible
aujourd'hui quand on regarde la montée
des populismes nationalisme
en europe ex europe de l'est on le voit
bien ici une extrême droite qui ne veut
plus dire son nom
une extrême droite qui touchent à
différents thèmes qu'elle ne touchez
jamais jusqu'à présent je pense à la
laïcité
qui aurait pu penser à un moment donné
que quand on va faire la gloire de
jeanne d'arc avec les croix de feu entre
guillemets modèle 21e siècle on parle de
laïcité donc on voit bien est ce que la
gauche n'a pas abandonné la laïcité la
gauche doit retrouver ses racines je
voulais 10 et imaginer un nouveau projet
politique pour notre pays et cette
gauche a besoin du parti socialiste j'en
suis intimement convaincu que les
socialistes sont pas quand même un peu
responsable de la montée du fn
86 la proportionnelle intégrale on a des
députés 36 députés qui arrive à
l'assemblée en 2014 européenne le rnb fn
à l'époque est en tête est ce que le
parti socialiste vous croyez même
certains ce que c'est un mode de scrutin
qui crée le mouvement politique dont ils
sont là depuis 86
ils sont ils représentent aujourd'hui
une forme de désespérance
j'évoquais avec un ami récemment la
situation invités du ps ma question
prenait le bassin minier
je connais bien un million deux cent
mille habitants de tiers dans le pas de
calais un tiers dans le département du
nord
les boyaux rouges sont devenus les
boyaux brun le chômage de masse
l'exaspération le sentiment de
déclassement de relégation ont donné les
classes mais je mesure parfaitement que
nous avons une responsabilité et la
gauche de se retrouvera que si elle
arrive à reconquérir ses classes
populaires qui sont aujourd'hui non pas
des classes populaires qui sont des
classes totalement isolé populaire au
sens sociologique du terme
mais avec un chômage de masse tels que
nous connaissons dans un département
comme le nôtre
et bien aujourd'hui ce sont des gens qui
ne croient plus en rien et finalement
les gilet jaune sont une expression
positive de personnes qui se disent
maintenant encore des choses à dire et
ça ce mouvement là méritait d'être
entendu peut-être plus qu'il ne l'a été
dans le cadre du grand débat
oriane vous parlez de la gauche est ce
que on a cinq candidats de gauche à
cette élection européenne est ce que
l'union de la gauche c'est l'ancien
monde
et moi je je suis né en politique avec
nom de la gauche mitterrand marché les
radicaux de gauche
voilà mais des partis de gauche pour
représenter un électorat puissant
à l'époque aujourd'hui tout est à
reconstruire est ce que le parti
socialiste pour être très clair est au
même stade que celui que connaissaient
l'aï sefyu à la fin des années 60 c'est
possible c'est possible mais il s'est
régénéré et il a recréé un nouveau
mouvement
ça a été possible aussi parce qu'il y
avait un certain françois mitterrand un
moment donné et permettez moi de dire
qu'il y avait aussi un pierre mauroy à
l'époque qui avait su tenir une langue
ils manquent de figure de ceux de ce
poids de ce charisme et est aujourd'hui
n'ont pas encore il faut rappeler
bernard cazeneuve françois mitterrand
sûrement pas en tout cas
françois hollande dans la case noël sont
deux voies qui sont fortes mais il ya
d'autres ministres qui ont marqué ce
quinquennat précédent
je pense par exemple à marisol touraine
avec qui je continue à avoir des
relations de travail qui vient cette
semaine chez nous de nous présenter son
avis sur la réforme des retraites voulue
par le gouvernement
donc ces voix là il faut les rajouter
non pas se soustraire mené rajouter au
travail l'envié fort pourquoi on ne les
entend plus les bergers d'efforts moi
j'hésite demandent qu'une seule chose
c'est que olivier faure qui le premier
secrétaire légitime du parti socialiste
aujourd'hui puissent aussi s'appuyer sur
ces bois forte c'est pas à la place deux
les uns la place des autres c'est tous
ensemble en dix ans mais nous portons
tous une part de vérité et françois
hollande à sa part de vérité
il dresse aujourd'hui non pas des murs
mais des ponts entre des personnes qui
aujourd'hui sont peut être éloignées les
unes des autres
l'archipel de la gauche pour reprendre
un mot aujourd'hui connues l'archipel de
la gauche mérite des ponts et si chacun
peut pas porter un pont et je pense que
nous serons 2% des électeurs socialistes
qui pense que la liste ps et la liste
des verts ont des projets politiques
proches est ce que vous trouvez pas vous
auriez dû quitte à vous ranger derrière
quelqu'un vous ranger derrière yannick
jadot pour qui l'effet 8%
on a proposé non pas en tête des listes
bataller ségolène royal qu'est ce
qu'elle a dit rappelez-vous bosch
défavorable cette commune où ségolène
royal une voix forte aussi empreint de
tout ce qui touche à la transition
écologique et qui avait proposé une aide
aux d'être la numéro deux de sa liste
pilotée par lui la réponse a toujours
été la même d'ailleurs il est constant
yannick jadot
je veux me comté je me compte et tout
seul c'est parce au vu de son côté
électorat alors dix ans mais l'élection
à la présidentielle saluerait non mais
l'élection européenne sélection qui
réussit au verbe toujours et donc chez
lui mais voilà je vais ramasser la mise
mais c'est un calcul à court terme et
olivier faure s'est battu pour qu'il y
ait une alliance benoît hamon et yannick
jadot etc
aujourd'hui nous avons une livre place
publique nouvelle donne
quelques transfuges ici ou là j'espère
que n'oublieront pas les radicaux de
gauche parliez du nom de la gauche tout
à l'heure et aussi le mouvement des
citoyens qui est très implanté dans ma
région et qui mérite d'être bien placé
pour reprendre l'expression d'olivier
forces est trop le bordel à gauche c'est
son expression je suis chez l'acteur où
j'ai joué un peu plus châtié en tout cas
c'est une cacophonie qui ne peut que
favoriser les extrêmes
même si aujourd'hui jean-luc mélenchon
est un peu en faiblesse mais tout ce qui
concourt à renforcer l'idée que le
peuple c'est contre les élites et que
les élites on comprend le peuple c'est
dangereux pour notre pays et ça c'est un
danger que nous devons prendre en
considération comme étant la tabulation
première aujourd'hui dans l'urgence pour
la gauche de se reconstruire dans la
sphère benalla le parquet a ouvert deux
nouvelles enquêtes après le signalement
du sénat est ce que ça vous réjouir le
sénat a fait son travail
je lui ai dit redit et sur tous les
plateaux après la remise du rapport
je considère que je travaille maintenant
pour de le côté terminé c'est à la
justice de faire son oeuvre
point barre senna quand même le fait
qu'elle passait en charge et pas moi à
dire ça donne raison par raison de la
crainte il épate extraire 11 et nous je
crois que le travail du sénat de du
président de la commission philippe bas
des deux co rapporteurs dont jean pierre
sueur qui est socialiste a été un
travail bien fait reconnu par le bureau
du sénat dans les conditions que vous
savez gérard larcher l'a considéré de la
même manière a transmis au parquet les
informations qui permettent au matin au
parquet je dirais d'asseoir son avis
laissons les choses se faire si comme
elle aimait lien vous auriez peut-être
dû différenciés selon vous de porter
c'est la connexion virtuelle a travaillé
six mois de manière intensive où l'avait
vu et transparente devant les français
nous on part créer une commission d'
enquête sur le sujet en tout cas je
crois que ce n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
parce que ça a été une bonne affaire une
bonne opération pour le sénat parce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui je crois dans la
restitution que simplement 20% des
français demandent la suppression du
sénat
ces vins mais sans trop 20% trop encore
français sur ça qu'est ce que vous
estimez que vous avez fait la
démonstration que ces night est
indispensable un contre-pouvoir
indispensable viser la lettre de aux
français de macron je pense qu'il reste
encore dans sa tête convaincu qu'une
alliance ou même une fusion entre le 6e
et le sénat aboutissant à une chambre
qui ne serait pas une chambre de beckham
bicamérisme donc il est clair il est
clair que le sénat n'est pas un
contre-pouvoir au sens fort que vous
évoquez mais participe à l'équilibré des
pouvoirs et notre pays notre démocratie
a besoin d'un équilibre des pouvoirs
surtout avec une majorité aussi forte à
l'armée nationale
donc ne touchons pas au sénat laissons
le travailler dans de bonnes conditions
alors on l'a vu dans cette émission tout
à l'heure avec le sénateur et l'air vous
avez des points d'accord mais il ya
aussi des points de divergences sur
certains textes et notamment la loi
anti-casseurs jeudi le conseil
constitutionnel a censuré l'article
phare de cette fois l'article 3 qui
permet au préfet d'interdire de
manifester pendant une durée d'un mois
sur l'ensemble du territoire qu'est ce
que vous avez pensé de cette décision
mais le conseil a dit le droit
tout simplement nous avons fait avec
d'autres collègues d'ailleurs un recours
devant le conseil constitutionnel nous
estimions à l'époque que l'article 3
était potentiellement attentatoires aux
libertés est donc très concrètement nous
sommes satisfaits de ce nom est ce qu'il
y aura une relecture avec d'autres
modèles délibération non
nous non mais s'il ya une nouvelle
délibération elle est possible dans le
cadre de la contrition
oui il a il l'a évoqué même si la partie
de son texte initial a été elle
confirmée notamment sur les visages
cachés dont ils devraient être
satisfaits des décisions du conseil
constitutionnel
moi je considère que heureusement que ce
recours a été possible
et heureusement qu'ils ont été conclues
positivement parce que le droit de
manifester est un droit fondamental et
ça ne peut pas être un fonctionnaire il
n'a pas le droit de dire qui qui peut ne
pas être d'accord sur l'idée qu'on peut
pas venir manifester par exemple que le
visage masqué cette mesure là j'ai ouï
dire parce que là il ya un internaute du
client et du maire en critiquant cette
loi anticasseurs vous donnez
l'impression de défendre les cas selon
bien sûr que non et je pense que ce
serait quand même mal venu de penser que
des gens responsables comme nous
puissions cautionner les casseurs
par contre vous me direz comment on est
capable de repérer un casseur parce
qu'il a un visage
basket ou simplement un manifestant qui
veut se protéger d'éventuels gaz
lacrymogènes donc ce sera très difficile
à mettre en avant une toute dernière
question municipal est municipal que
vous souhaitez être candidat à lille en
2020 je suis dit waouh né à lille ma
question je vais vous dire je n'en sais
rien ce que je sais c'est que
aujourd'hui cette ville de lille fait
l'objet de beaucoup d'appétit la part de
république en marche mais aussi de la
part de monsieur 4 nas députés bien
connu de la france insoumise et donc moi
en tant que socialistes lillois
je n'ai pas envie que le beffroi bascule
d'un côté ou de l'autre et que donc je
prendrai ma part à la place qui sera la
mienne en lien bien sûr avec le maire de
lille que je salue martine aubry avec
qui je souhaite dialoguer naturellement
je crois vous êtes à miami alors m'est
donnée je n'ai pas encore vu martine
aubry je vous dirai ce que je veux dire
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que il
faut rajouter et non pas soustraire et
ce beffroi
j'y tiens comme la prunelle de mes yeux
voilà message transmis à martine aubry
elle veut se représenter elle peut
compter sur vous pour sauver le dos rond
je ne suis pas d'indépendance
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous merci mesdames bonsoir à
tous et à très vite
merci à vous
et